let me ask you about one of the most
complex geopolitical situations in
history
um one aspect of it is the cold war
between Iran and Israel the bigger
picture of it is sometimes referred to
as uh
israel-palestine conflict
what are all the parties Nations
involved what are the interests that are
involved what's the rhetoric
um can you understand make the case for
each side of this conflict
you're opening a new can of worms that
it takes another three hours of of
conversation just three hours at least
what what I can tell you is this
Iran prior to 1979
viewed itself under the shaw as a kind
of
if that's supporter of Israel
was in very good terms with Israel they
had an embassy in Iran or unofficial
Embassy you know there are certain
projects that's helping with the
Agriculture and so forth you know
but since 1979
that completely reversed
part of it is that the issue of the
Palestinian plights
remained very much at the heart
of
the Revolutionary Iranians who would see
that
part of the United States is to support
part of the United States guilt
sin
is to support Israel
vis-a-vis it's very suppressive
very
oppressive
treatment of the Palestinians completely
illegal taking over of the territories
which is not theirs since 1967.
and therefore it is upon the Iranian
regime Iranian Islamic Republic to
support the cause of the Palestinians
this came about at the time
when
the rest of the support for the
Palestinians including Arab nationalism
basically
reached a stage of bankruptcy
I mean much of the regimes of the Arab
world either are now coming to terms
with Israel or in one way or another
because of their own contingencies
because of their own
concerns and interests
are really nearly accepting
Israel in the in the region now that all
task of rhetorically supporting the
Palestinians falls upon the Islamic
Republic
that sees itself as the champion of the
Palestinians now without as a matter of
fact having either the support of the
Iranian people behind him if you ask if
tomorrow there would be a poll or a
referendum I would doubt that
eighty percent of the Iranian people
would approve of the policies of the
Islamic Republic vis-a-vis the issue of
Palestine
nor the Palestinians themselves because
they're
the Islamic Republic is only supporting
those factions within the Palestinian
movement which are Islamic quote-unquote
and even within that they there is
problems with Hamas for instance
but nevertheless it's for the Islamic
Republic some kind of a propaganda tool
to be able to use it for its own sake
and claim that we are the champions of
the Palestinian people
whether they have a solution
if you look at the rhetoric if you
listen to the rhetoric it's the
destruction of the
state of Israel
and that's
seems to me creates a certain anxiety in
the minds of the Israelis Israeli
population and Israeli government
particularly those who are now in power
Netanyahu the liquid
and more kind of a right wing politics
of police polity of today's Israel
that being said I think also the
Israelis try to get an extra mileage out
of
uh threat of Iran quote-unquote
in order to
present themselves
a rightful to for terms of security and
whatever else
the way that they're treating the
Palestinians which I think is extremely
unjust I think it's extremely unwise
for Israel to carry on with these
policies as they did since 67 at least
and not to try to come to terms with it
of course there are huge amount of
I'm not denying that at all it's a huge
amount of
uh uh failures mistakes
and stupidity on the side of the
Palestinian leadership
in various stages
not to try to make a deal
or try to come to terms in some fashion
but it's a very complex picture and it's
rather unfair to the Palestinians to
accuse them for not coming to terms with
Israel under a very uneven circumstances
when they are not in a position to try
to make a fair deal in terms of the
territories
or in terms of their security in future
vis-a-vis Israel so I think there is as
you probably know quite a lot of people
that would have a different perspective
than you just stated in terms of
you know taking the perspective of
Israel and characterizing the situation
Can you steal man that at their side can
you still man Israel's side that they're
trying to be a Sovereign Nation trying
to protect themselves against threats
ultimately
wanting to create a place of safety a
place where people can pursue
all all the things that you want to
pursue in life including foremost
happiness
I tend to agree with you
and I have all the respect for the fact
that
Israel would like to create security and
happiness for its own people
but there are two arguments is one is a
moral argument
to my mind as a historian
a uh Jews across around the world for
all through their history suffered
and this is a history of suffering there
is a memory of something
and they find it enormously difficult to
believe that a nation that's the product
of so much
uh sacrifice suffering loss of life
and a variety of Holocaust above all
would find itself in a position not to
give the proper Justice to a people who
could be their neighbors
and that is a moral argument which I
cannot believe under any circumstances
can be accepted second in real terms
what do you want to you want to commit
to genocide
do you have a population there
that you have to come to terms with it
and you cannot just postpone as they did
667 they are postponing and hoping that
it goes away somehow
I don't think it's going to go away
and and it's going to get worse right
and better
it's a long nuanced discussion and I
look forward to having it
so just leave it
um there for the moment
uh but it is
a stressful place in the world uh where
the rhetoric is existential we're on
yeah it makes claims that he wants to
wipe a country off the face of the Earth
it's just the level of of intensity of
rhetoric is unlike anywhere else in the
world and extremely dangerous and in in
both directions so one the real Danger
the rhetoric actually being acted upon
and then the extreme
political parties using the rhetoric to
justify
even a greater escalation
so uh yeah if Iran is saying that this
is it's saying that they're wanting to
wipe Israel off the face of the Earth
that justifies any response
uh on the other side on the other side
of course I tend to agree with you fully
and unfortunately this is a very
critical situation that uh this region
is facing Iran in particular
I would say that
um
I hope that in the minds of the people
of Israel
there is a enough or common sense to
realize that
probably escalation on the Israeli side
is not in the favor of anybody
and try to let the Iranians to go on
with their
empty rhetoric
as they do so far but
at the same time I cannot deny the fact
that
you know there is a danger on the side
of this regime and what it says it
cannot be denied nobody can justify that
uh particularly because the Iranian
population is not behind this regime
certainly in the case of the
Palestinians or for that matter it's not
Palestine it's the the the
Islamic Republic's involvement in
Lebanon with Hezbollah it's the Islamic
Republic's involvement in Syria with
pasture Assad its involvement in other
parts of the World perhaps even Yemen
that all of them creates extra
territorial
responsibilities or interventions
unnecessary interventions
that ultimately is not in favor of
best interests of the Iranian people or
Iran as a country Iran has never been
involved in this kind of politics before
after the Islamic Republic so in a sense
the Iranian regime it seems to me by
going to the extreme try to create for
itself
a
space
that it did not have or did not deserve
to have
within the politics of the region he
said so in other words that has become
part of the tool a kind of an instrument
for if you like to call it some kind of
an expansionism
of of the regime uh in parts of the
world where it can see there is the
possibility
for its presence for its expansion
of course historically speaking Iran
ever since 15th century I think that's
the earliest example I can see
in mother in alibade times has always a
tendency of moving in the direction
of not only what is today the state of
Iraq but further into the eastern coast
of mediterranea so that's a long-term
ambition that has been in the cards as
far as
Iran as a strategic unit is cancer but
by no means Justified and by no means
could be a reasonable could be a sane
policy of a nation state as today's Iran
but the second point is that also
regimes are always victims of their own
rhetoric
so it's I once you keep repeating
something
then you become more and more committed
to it
and it cannot remain anymore in the
level of a rhetoric you have to do
something about it so it's something
compelling pressure
to try to uh to uh to materialize what
you've been saying in your rhetoric and
that is even extremely more dangerous
as far as Iran is concerned
and it brings it to some Unholy
alliances
that today we are witnessing Iran is
getting involved even more dangerous
than this rhetoric uh in in terms of the
visible Israel is its involvement with
uh Russia and to some extent with China